Beverly is with us in Baltimore Maryland
hi Beverly how are you hi how are you
doing better than I deserve what's up
good question about loan forgiveness
I'm peers into a public service loan
forgiveness forum before I'm student
loans the ten year right okay I'm in my
late 50s and looking to retire and about
10 to 12 years and so my question is how
much does one IV not two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars Oh Lord right on
what what'd you guys do you become a
doctor
no what you do that is our program
manager a what program manager well what
kind of programs do you manage for
250,000 oh not enough
what company this wasn't it this wasn't
a good decision so I mean what's your
income I'm Colleen 2120 so my question
is do I just let this ride out for eight
years and get the rest of it forgiven or
should I do the pay off the debt I would
pay it off eight years is just too long
but I know it's it's a huge mountain but
I mean let's go ahead and get Everest
climbed and just knock it out as fast as
you possibly can you're gonna be living
on beans and rice rice and beans because
you have made a as you said a large mess
here and so anything you can do to get
your income up and your outgo down and
just live on nothing let's say you did
that and you put sixty thousand dollars
a year towards this what y'all be able
to do that seventy thousand dollars a
year you're done in three years and
that's where I want you to be I don't I
don't want to put anybody in a jail cell
for eight years and that's what you're
facing here because you basically got no
life at all I mean if this thing owns
you and I would just I would
say this thing has to go and I've got to
do whatever it takes that's legal and
moral to get it done and clean it up as
fast as I possibly can Wow
ouch thanks for calling in